hello there reject nation we're gonna
watch today gravity falls season two
episode two two by two if you guys can
join us on our patreon and become a
super sexy reject by checking out all
the crap we gotta offer over there
including the full-length watch alongs
for this show and if you can't do that
please leave a like and subscribe too so
you can get notified when our reaction
for the next gravity falls is up here on
the chanel and uh also then boys at
prepper thanks for helping us edit these
down you sexy sons of bees let's get to
it
[Music]
ah my face is being eaten a lot
sadly ain't pretty no more
second
poor chadley just look at these texts
winky frown what does that even mean
not like seeing any other guys or meet
my new boyfriend dude
right you [ __ ] if if you and me whatever
i mean if maybe you
wanted to join me and mabel on this
mystery hunt tomorrow conspiracy stuff
and all that that's all yeah dude i love
doing junk with friends
oh she said it
that's all we'll ever be
oh
friends
i got a dude
why is there brochures on the bed
yeah well you know this is a show for it
for young adults you know
gotta get a little edgy acknowledge that
our bodies are changing who wrote this
journal
30 years ago the author vanished without
a trace but according to this new clue
we may have found his secret hiding
place
jk rowling that's right dude i'm so
stoked about this i've been wanting to
go adventuring with you guys sherbet's
picking up after my dad at home
oh ow
who put that wall there
[Laughter]
what a man inviting wendy on our mission
me thinks there's romance afoot no look
mabel i've thought this through and i'm
over wendy you're over windy allow me to
put on my skepticals
[Laughter]
[Music]
she is the daughter of her parents
boosh
you're about to learn the truth of
gravity falls
is this haunted room actually stretching
whatever happens down there we tell no
one
now who wants to go first you will
dipper
[Music]
this is so stupid cool attack on titan
this is going over my bed
it's like he was preparing for a
disaster but what kind of disaster would
need supplies for over 60 years where's
the best kind of disaster oh my gosh
a smells dispenser
guess i will have some of your old timey
face food
you dusted
wait a minute
[Music]
no
was this place built in the past or the
future yeah this room is way creepy not
as creepy as dipper's internet history
[Music]
it won't
stop zipper what do we do where do the
caterpillars go come on come on
find these four symbols qrik everybody
step on one well that's lucky
whoa no he lost his one jacket i know
where is he gonna get another get a load
of this crazy surveillance room check it
out dudes
seuss
that is hilarious
the best
no lives wendy i've always had a crush
on
oh my gosh hey dipper
what i found
what are you give me that i know what i
know and i know it you're not over
winning
just drop it okay dude differ you gotta
check out this weird metal closet
i am a robot i have a metal closet
[Laughter]
he wants to tell her but he's scared
maybe a little push good idea mabel
thanks mabel that face
[Music]
mabel let us out as soon as you tell
wendy that thing you've been wanting to
tell her you'll thank me for this later
what is she talking about
maple's just been eating raw sugar
packets again
oh yeah let me out right now ugh where
are the lights
whoa
yes differs internet history
[Music]
what the
hell
whoa
hidden lamb
maybe the author did experiments down
here dexter went crazy what do you think
dug all these tunnels let's hope we
don't find out
what
open up for real there's a monster in
here
nice try the only monsters are your own
inner demons dipper
[Laughter]
just say whatever mabel wants you to say
so she'll let us out of here i
i
i'm gonna find another way out
what do we do i don't know
huh oh my god it's the original guy
well i just ripped off
boy
it's you hurry now i scared it off but
it'll regenerate
it's the doctor why did you build this
bunker it's one of my experiments a
shape-shifter able to take the form of
anyone or anything it seems is that
burke hamill i was just trying to figure
it out you might be right trying to
catch the creature alone but now you're
here wow
you helped me catch it
look at this tubie thing
oh yeah oh no like the fly experiment
number 210 the shape shifter
shapeshifter uh dude didn't dippers say
there was a monster in there with them
huh i thought he was just joking you
know dipper's jokes are terrible
i don't get many non-mold people
visitors more people lost my journal so
many years ago i found one of them it's
how i tracked you down here
my boy i can't express my gratitude oh
yes
after all these years
oh my god he's malevolent oh
yes yes
it's all here wendy isn't it amazing
we're actually meeting the real author
dipper
[ __ ]
oh
oh no he's a shape-shifter uh you know
what we should probably get going no
he's the thing gross what did you do to
the real author you'll likely never find
him that six-fingered nerd hasn't been
himself in 30 years so many wonderful
forms to take
hey
that group
pretty much
[Music]
[Music]
wow oh they're windy mabel zeus wait
careful ah they're not the shapeshifter
maybe i am mabel expect my shape oh what
happened we got attacked by the
shapeshifter he broke out of his cage
pretended to be the author and wants
dipper's journal
what a badass what do we do well he took
us into his home tricked us and tried to
destroy us
i say we return the favor my god sarah
khan
reveal yourself you single form human
weakling
oh
there you are who
had a new one wow what a form should i
be one
or the other
how about both
wow wow that is terrifying yeah
no no no no
it's not working dude
dude
no
save her dipper
[Music]
oh no
that shine i told you when we were in
the closet we wouldn't be in this mess
but i was too scared and now you could
be hurt or worse and i never even got a
chance to tell you i'm like
in love with you wendy oh
that's so sad
[Music]
oh
oh this is bad hit her with the ass
don't listen to her dipper she's the
shape shifter give me a sign
nice
you will never find the author if you
keep digging you'll need our fate worse
than you can imagine and this will be
the last form you ever take
oh
no
good luck sleeping tonight
[Music]
my face hurts from doing this all day
yeah we gotta admit we're all total
heroes hey who wants to get some heroes
breakfast huh no wendy go with that
wendy about earlier in the heat of the
moment i might have said some dumb
things and
can't we just pretend none of that ever
happened dude dude it's okay
i always kind of knew
wait you did oh
i mean you think i can't hear that stuff
you're constantly whispering under your
breath
thank you i have more fun with you than
like practically anybody else and if you
ever stop being my friend
i would like throw myself into the
bottomless pit you get shot back up yeah
yeah that's right that's not a big risk
[Laughter]
if you can handle that monster you can
handle a little awkwardness
oh yeah dude friends
oh okay
see you for movie night tomorrow your
place this time okay
[Music]
i think she's taking pure advantage of
the man
[Laughter]
i just wanted to bring you movies and
take you on adventures still bummed
we're no closer to finding the author
guy at least i got his sciencey coat and
briefcase that's not a briefcase that's
a laptop and it really busted up one too
i bet i could get this thing fixed up in
a few days it's gonna take a lot of duct
tape
f
the founders it's just me or does
gravity falls tv only have the worst
movies you're watching the gravity falls
bargain movie showcase coming up next
the widdlest vampire oh yeah
[Music]
my mummy's a werewolf attack of the
exclamation points
the man with no taste
ghost turtle
i want all these this again this again
watch this channel again
oh oh
that was mark campbell
dude
it's a good
versatile shape-shifting performance
yeah
i could always hear that joker anywhere
yeah
that rasp
that was a great episode man
absolutely absolutely vodka
that was a great great episode uh
i love that one a lot
i just
rest with that emotion for just a tiny
bit because yeah that was that was
really solid had so much heart and
you got to see this layer of wendy
because she's she is like that like
independent girl movie character in a
lot of ways you know free spirited
adventurous dry sense of humor but
probably one of the most compassionate
people you'll ever meet yeah yeah she
really has that character about her
character um but this time you really
got to see a lot more of her tougher
side her uh lumberjack side and i
thought that was really cool to
implement here in such a
a a underground adventure with uh
something that they really took
advantage of their their supernatural
character this time around
and they really let it
it really accentuated what you can do
with the shapeshifter yeah and they they
committed to the horror of it there were
some pretty terrifying effects i thought
they really utilized the animation very
well on that front and i i really
enjoyed that a lot and everyone was
really enjoyable everyone not much uncle
sam but
i didn't miss his presence this time
around and i really loved uh having
this be the cord of the youth characters
i liked having uh this ensemble for
this particular venture especially
because grunkle stands under the
impression
that
dipper is not going to be doing this
[ __ ] anymore
well we know somehow it will tie
together but for right now i think that
this was really solid and then tulsa air
all that jazz between wind winding dips
dips mcgee
what's going on i'm dipping i'm just
dipping into like a honey pot mm-hmm
yeah
that's that's that's what the kids want
yeah i like that this is the episode
where they're like no no this thing's a
disney channel this is disney xd all
right we can get a little scarier we can
get a little more honest about you know
the emotions you experience when you're
a young teenager or whatever
and uh yeah it's that's like a specific
thing that's always an awkward
conversation i feel like but it's yeah
it's like you know he's what 12 or
something and she's like 15. so yeah
there's that that's right she's 20 years
this is highly illegal romeo and juliet
laws do not apply
her friendship is inappropriate yeah
you should be often
at work or something
uh anyway yeah no i i i this appealed to
me in all the right ways you know like i
already love the kind of
you know conspiracy
secret laboratory hidden underneath the
spiral staircase tree like all that
stuff and then it becoming
yeah this shapeshifter story like i love
the misdirect of that and uh yeah you
think you meet the guy and you get that
initial catharsis like every time it
took a turn where i was expecting one
thing it would just keep developing
which was nice
which made it feel like a really
kind of uh straight like like a real
i don't want to say real story i feel
like that slights everything else but
yeah it made it feel like a different
kind of story and uh one that really has
that adventurous spirit and that yeah
utilized all the characters well cut
back and forth appropriately like
motivated certain things like you know
the cryotank is gonna come back but at
the same time it's placed well enough
that you're like oh yeah you know that's
just kind of a fun thing they're doing
amidst all these kind of wacky things
that are down here but yeah i love that
you have this sort of bonding experience
that does ultimately partly come down to
them like knowing each other very well
and then yeah it becomes the thing and
then it has a really sort of nice
emotional conversation
uh that
i don't know like it had a nice nuance
about it you know i feel like i haven't
seen
that conversation for characters in that
you know kind of position age-wise
especially get to have a conversation
like that on screen i'm sure it's
happened i'm sure there are good
examples of it but this was a nice
example of that i thought every woman in
my life
well you should record them and just
send them all to me and i'll say they're
going man you good what a great scene
your life is
um but yeah yeah and even didn't miss
grunkle stan uh funny enough i feel like
that's kind of nice too i like when
shows let certain characters be off
screen for a while and then you know
he's got his own like wily
things he's getting up to
so
yeah i like that we're unpacking what
the true mystery behind gravity falls
really is
and like instead of just creating a
world of gravity falls where
supernatural shenanigans take place
they're really
creating a lore to it and i think that's
really cool where i didn't expect the
show to go down that direction i just
sort of accepted that dipper found some
journal yeah that has answers
these will be the monsters of the week
yeah i like that they're created they're
crap they're crafting a real narrative
to it and you know when you pair off
like mabel and seuss together uh they
you'd think that kind of be an annoying
pair but they really complement each
other well they do and i really liked i
really liked wendy a lot in this episode
especially um
that conversation
at the end did feel
poignant in a lot of ways you know like
that's probably one of the best
it's it's the kind of thing of you know
you can be
when you are teenagers that is a real
struggle especially if you do have an
older friend or something like that
older girl especially usually doesn't
date the younger guy yeah
um and it's it is very different like 25
and 28 is not the same thing as like 12
and 15 yeah exactly
just dif very different mature levels
and
i i like the way they handle that where
you can see them being friends and that
you just get this out of the air and
then
past it you know
um yeah i i thought this was a excellent
excellent episode it was exciting too
was it an exciting episode
it it had me going you know
and i i at both times where
you think you're with a human but it's
not
like when dipper was like confessing his
love to what he thought when he might be
d might be dead i was getting pretty
emotional over that and then they reveal
that she's
that there's the shifter who's like wow
this is really
pulling you in directions here yeah i
wasn't even thinking about that when
that reveal came around yeah they knew
how to mislead you and then
even with her when they do the the way
they drew attention to like
you can't tell anyone here that each
the camera takes a turn to show each one
of them expression giving the
the sign of agreement
and then wendy does this specifically
different from the other two
like they it was smart they gave a they
gave her a
more of a pause
so you wonder what she's going to do
and then she does that eventually
that way you remember what she did
without drawing attention because i was
it didn't stand out to me that there was
more of a beat before she did her thing
and then she did that so that way when
it came down to deciding which which
wendy's the real wendy to do that i'm
like oh that was clever because it was
so
it didn't draw much attention but they
did just enough so you would remember
why you remember that move you know
because if it was just like
you probably wouldn't remember yeah yeah
then it's more of like a timing based
gag whereas here yeah they really well
placed and motivated and paid off these
different motifs that would come back
and they i don't know i guess that's
just good writing and direction when
yeah they've got you so engrossed in the
tone they want to have happening and so
much of that tone is either like
it's good that they have such like a fun
intriguing mystery at the core because
that motivates i think us to
be just as eager to look past it to the
next development or whatever and that
creates a very sort of lively setting
for all these you know concurrent
emotional things to take place yeah and
uh yeah yeah this is this was like
really uh
like
so gracefully put together for as you
know kind of horrific and bombastic as
parts of it got and i like that they
were willing and able to go there yeah
the way they the the way they do imbue
uh the
the personal
relatable struggles is some of my
favorites that this show does
and i thought this actually had the
best pulse to it of
going back and forth with that ticking
clock of like mabel forcing dipper into
confessing his love
like they weaved in and out of it and
kept both just rising like he's gonna
have to tell her and they're dealing
with crazy shape-shifter they knew how
to switch back and forth between the two
intensities really well
and i i really appreciated the i thought
it was like a really well done just a
strongly executed episode
all right gang well gravity falls
episode two what do you all
think
uh leave your thoughts down below tell
us why you love this episode and hey uh
let's do a paint
everett pixelmybaker
everett
what can we say my friend you are the
last that we saved for best this month
or flip that around you know what i'm
trying to say we originally recorded you
a shout out on brooklyn nine-nine last
week the episode perished and along with
it your shout out so we are here today
to make it up to you to express the love
that maybe dipper was afraid we're not
afraid to express to you because everett
i mean just listen to the sound of that
name everett it flows but it's got a
little bit of that little little
percussive whip crack at the end to make
you to let us know
you know that you're engaged that you're
locked in that you're with us and we
appreciate you so everett pixel might
the mightiest
though he may be
pixelesque ins i don't know what your
stature is man but either way i want to
zoom in on the might part parts you're a
mighty mighty lovely fella you are a
baker of the breads of our souls and
dreams and we love you we'll see you
next month
[Music]
you